such- und champagner heißt das neue
album von sargent darüber reden wir und
darüber warum man mit dem rappen aufhört
wenn er eine familie gründet das und
mehr jetzt im talk bis dann packen
halli hallo ja jetzt ist die lage
die lage ist hervorragend ja eigentlich
schon immer mal was sagen ja obwohl
manche leute die wie erst sollte
eigentlich nicht fragen wie ist die lage
sondern eher fragen wie es die
slipanlage okay bei wem zum beispiel ich
musste jetzt kein feuer legen okay also
er ist kommen wir vielleicht später noch
drauf aber weißt du was mir jetzt
aufgefallen ist sonnenbrille zum rapper
rapper und sonnenbrille das ist eine
einheit voll warum eigentlich ich weiß
nicht ich denke mal das macht das ganze
ein bisschen
unantastbarer man ist so ein bisschen
abgeschirmt auf der anderen seite habe
ich gestern ein konzert gegeben
köln deshalb bin ich halt noch
angeschlagen
vom samstag also ein bisschen wie sowie
sowie bei heino der hatte er aber der
hat große augen die haben nicht genüge
und der hat sich dann besonnen oder
zugelegt so zog und champagner jetzt
heißt dein zweites album ja
es klingt doch schon beim eu-gipfel das
heißt was ist das für eine kombination
und da kommt das aus deinem namen
summerjam
nee das ist dann später so erzählt wo
ich das erste mal snc gepasst aber
geschrieben hat wo passt er super
duke und champagner sind ja wie zwei
gegensätze wenn du siehst du bist ja
eher so der mittelstand champagner
wiederum ist was edel ist ein edler
tropfen und das ist halt das
symbolisiert auch ein bisschen
die welt oder die zwei welten zwischen
denen wir pendeln oder
händler das ist die türkische und die
deutsche welt auch ich würde das jetzt
nicht türkisch deutschen ich meine es
gibt ja auch deutsche die aus dem
gleichen
sozialen stand kommen wie ich
schutz gar nicht so auffällt 10 in
schutz er sagen die untere mittelschicht
und die upper class okay ich wollte eine
elegante überleitung finden zur
zusammensetzung eines albums bei da ist
auch türkischer rap drauf genau das ist
auch türkischer web drauf da ist der
gute defcon drauf der rap dorf türkisch
meines erachtens der beste türkische
rapper den die musikwelt je gehört hat
und
ich habe mich selber auch in türkisch im
türkischen bereich ein bisschen mal
angetastet hat mal ein song gemacht der
ist zwar nicht auf dem album drauf aber
der wird auch bald erscheinen deshalb
täglich ist natürlich ein thema was für
mich immer relevant bleiben wird ist
türkischer rap also ist klingt
wahnsinnig schnell ist türkische sprache
besser eigentlich zum rappen geeignet
als deutsche das habe ich mich auch mal
gefragt wo ich so gesehen habe dass die
leute das ist auf jeden fall ein
bisschen besser zum rollen glaube ich es
rollt ein bisschen besser ich finde auch
ich find an sich deutsch ist immer so
ein bisschen
weiß ich nicht ein bisschen gehackter so
ist sagt er aufflog und der ist mit
deutscher schlager schwieriger ja ich
würde jetzt nicht unbedingt schwieriger
sagen aber ich denke englisch hat sich
für die leute direkt schon cool an beim
deutschen muss doppelt so viel gas geben
wahrscheinlich damit sich überhaupt
bisschen cool anhört als ich noch jung
war und das ist eine ganze weile her da
konnte sich keiner vorstellen dass je
auf deutsch gerappt wird die forscher
das war vollkommen unvorstellbar und
dann ist es passiert was was hat
deutschrap so gesellschaftsfähig gemacht
war das so auch neue deutsche welle ein
bisschen die da die die ebene oder den
weg geebnet hat ich würde das gar nicht
von der musikwelt abhängig waren schutz
er sofort
von von der situation in deutschland
abhängig machen weil ich glaube einfach
dass so die schere zwischen arm und
reich dadurch dass es immer größer wird
und dadurch das halt auch viele
ausländer mit rein gekommen sind das ist
so den grundstein für abgelegt hatten
gab es quasi für das ist ja gerade die
argumentiert hier da gibt's die
schichten gab es quasi für die den
leuten schlecht geht keine musik
kann sein klar wenn du nur über weiß ich
nicht wenn immer nur friede freude
eierkuchen ist weiß ich nicht ob man das
so unbedingt ob ein mensch der
sonntags die zwölf stunden schicht
mitgenommen hat ob er unbedingt weiß ich
nicht irgendwie was lustiges sich am
ende auch der eher ein sich rein ziehen
möchte der
das ganze sag ich mal verurteilt oder
sich ab fakt darüber den songs ist nicht
wobei du bist einer der wenigen wo ich
so raus höhere hey ich setze mich aber
auch kritisch damit auseinander mit der
ganzen situation wenn ich jetzt wie
heißt es was du mit motrip gemacht hast
immer noch hier immer noch hier da geht
es ja eben um jemand der sagt er ich
mache so ich mache so jetzt hier meine
karriere aber am schluss ist ja immer
noch nicht weitergekommen oder auch bei
kanak
habe ich den eindruck dass
wird nicht nur verherrlicht sondern hey
dann wird auch gesagt ja das ist
vielleicht nicht der richtige weg ist
das dein ist dass die botschaft
rüberbringen willst auf jeden fall ich
sag mal so ich kenne jeden erdenklichen
weg wie man geld machen kann ja und ist
das leben ich sag mal so dass dreht sich
nicht nur um dieses geld machen aber es
ist ein fester bestandteil und ich finde
jetzt nicht so dass ich jeden weg cool
finde es gibt natürlich einen viel
besseren weg wenn man
technisch einer der studiert einer der
irgendwie in allen job hat
gutes einkommen wer soll seinen weg
machen und alles andere möchte ich aber
jetzt auch nicht so mega kritisieren
also ich bin ich verherrliche das nicht
aber ich möchte auch nicht sagen das ist
voll scheiße die jungs die von der
straße sind und ich selber aus diesem
umfeld komme kann ich das auch gar nicht
aber was ist für dich so für dich die
coolste art geld zu verdienen man das
geld wäre einfach wenn ich so und enkel
sein könnte wenn ich einfach vom beruf
sohn wenn mein vater jetzt von von grund
auf reich gewesen wäre wäre der hammer
gewesen warum nicht aber sonst geht
macht eure schule macht euren weg alles
andere das ist schön das geht schnell
aber ist immer mit einem guten risiko
behaftet wie bis gewinn wir welchen weg
hast du gewählt ich habe den weg ich
hab' ich bin jahrelang zweigleisig
gefahren ich sag mal so musik es ist ja
mittlerweile amtlich bei sony scheint
schon jetzt dass ich sage ich bin jetzt
auch rapper oder so ich habe einen
vertrag ich bin bei sony springer
alpenrose verdienen geld damit
klar damals habe ich wo es noch nicht so
fest war habe ich bin ich natürlich
zweigleisig gefahren habe ich nebenbei
noch meine sachen gemacht ich will jetzt
nicht sagen dass alles alles alles
kriminell war aber ist gab es in sachen
die
die wenn ich eine andere möglichkeit
gehabt hätte oder wenn ich wie ich
gerade eben schon gesagt hatte von haus
auf wohl haben wohl habe gewesen wäre
hätte es nicht machen müssen deshalb ich
bin froh darüber jetzt mit der mutter
auf jeden fall meine kohle zu verdienen
ist ja irgendwas klar jetzt kannst du
immer irgendwas reden was so eingestellt
hast
es gibt eine sache da
eine ganze nation
dann hat für mich schwerer schlag für
eine andere person würde ich dann aber
im rennen sind das echt ist es dann mal
nicht verjährt ach nee die macht es noch
heute okay aber
wie wir sie bei dem in der schule
ausgang was hast du vom schulabschluss
gemacht oder hast du keinen immer doch
ich habe ein viele leute werden sich
noch wundern ich habe abitur
nichtsdestotrotz bin ich der meinung
wenn man
aus dem umfeld kommt wo ich komme wo ich
herkomme wo man wirklich schon früh wo
ein früh geld über die hand gegangen ist
dass man auch selbstständig sehr selbst
viel machen kann also ich könnte
selbstständig das geld was ich so
verdienen kann mit meinem kopf das
könnte ich als bürohengst niemals
verdienen niemals niemals auch nicht
wenn er studiert hätte deshalb der weg
da ist es ja nicht nur
das macht mir auch spaß was haben denn
deine eltern gesagt einvernahmen abi da
das erstmal nicht so den irgendeinen
regulären weg beschritten bist
was sagen deine eltern sind
die sind natürlich schon von grund auf
nicht gut anzusprechen auf musik so die
er war hatten natürlich einen grund
abgetönt geschmack das war ohne dass sie
irgendwie groß wussten wenn die wüssten
nun was ich für texte rapper jetzt
wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer
aber die für die ist das nichts
greifbares
die wollen ein blatt papier haben wo was
wohl stempel drauf ist staatlich geprüft
blablabla draufsteht
aber mit der zeit wo ist dann halt ein
bisschen amtlicher wurde wo die ersten
verträge die ersten videos die ersten
sachen im fernsehen kam haben wir das
akzeptiert die feiern das immer noch
nicht die finden das immer noch nicht
die würden sich auch wünschen dass ich
irgendwie was anderes gemacht hätte ich
habe ja auch alle voraussetzungen
ihrer meinung nach gehabt und wie ist
das denn wenn du jetzt mit deinen eltern
zu tun hast redet ihr dann immer um
waisen brei herum oder gibt streit oder
also macht ihren
streit nicht streit nicht springen ja
auch geld nach hause das wäre
schwachsinn wenn sie wenn sie jetzt
streiten ich drücke jeden monat so viel
ab dass
das mir kein einziges wort zu ohren
kommt ok also das ist eine wichtige
bedingung das ist keine bedingungen von
meinen eltern das mache ich von mir aus
freien stücken und spielen einfach nur
zeigen dass ich ein schwachkopf bin so
dass ich meine kohle nur vor ballack
lafer ballerspiel aber ich bin auch so
ich denke auf jeden fall auch an die
leute die mit mir sind und ich denke
auch an die zukunft es heißt immer mein
blutdruck stress ab und ufa palast eine
menge du musst ja wahnsinnig viel geld
verdienen
fragt nicht so viel sie
kosten die auch so normalen
taschenrechner posten diese zu halten
ich leider nicht okay wobei ich ja
unterschiedlich dieses höhere das web
business ist ja wahnsinnig schwieriges
die album verkäufe funktionieren nicht
immer auf macht manchmal macht man es
eben hier über ihr t shirt summerjam
sehr schick mit kussmund
also dir selbst verschiedenste
aber du kommst damit zurecht ich komme
auf jeden fall damit zurecht ich bin zur
zeit auf tour ich verdiene auto mein
geld ich habe auch so öfter auftritt
ich habe einen will wo ich immer wieder
mal was bekomme
nebenbei gibt es natürlich auch noch
andere sachen die man macht man sieht
jetzt nur die cds aber cd ist er ich
würde jetzt mittlerweile sogar sagen das
hauptgeschäftsfeld es jetzt nicht mehr
cd verkäufe sondern
virgin da ist man kann auch pilz mit
irgendwelchen
also irgendwelche kooperation haben im
internet wie einem kohle bringen ich
meine als rapper ich habe mir jetzt
letztens sagen lassen es gibt keine
musikrichtung wie so eine krasse
reichweite hat im internet anbietet und
deshalb das ist ja alles was wert auch
wenn ich jetzt über hunderttausend
klicks bei facebook gehabt ist das geld
das bargeld und man muss nur alt den
passenden deckel zum topf finden
absoluten dass der berg passenden deckel
ist
der passende deckel ist irgendeine seite
die zum beispiel zu mir sagt wie sieht
es aus wenn wir zusammenarbeiten klar
aber es gibt so und so und so ok das
heißt ein mann wird mehr geschäftsmann
im rap geschäft als musiker du musst auf
jeden fall geschäftsmann sein anders
wäre es wahrscheinlich wenn du weißt
rockstar bist dann kannst du
wahrscheinlich jeden tag beim ballern
und sich frei fühlen und ein paar
hotelzimmer auseinandernehmen beim wenn
rapper bis kann es das einmal die woche
machen aber sechs tage muss auch mal ein
bisschen anderen business denken okay
hast du manchmal angst vor der zukunft
ist so eine sache
ich sag mal finanziell überhaupt nicht
mache ich mir gar keine sorgen damit war
schon immer mehr auch als kleines kind
ich wusste direkt wie man was macht dich
ab schon früh geschaltet
wie diese wirtschaftlichen dinge laufen
ich glaube nicht dass ich irgendwann mal
weiß ich nicht den hunger tod erleiden
muss und da haben wir auch einen guten
vorrat
besorgt
aber das einzige was man sich so denkt
ist natürlich
als ich 15 16 17 war da hatte ich
natürlich ganz andere vorstellungen im
kopf wie wo ich jetzt bin da wäre weiß
ich nicht da war wahrscheinlich wäre ich
jetzt verheiratet gewesen hätte ich
schon zwei drei kinder und ein mal im
jahr türkei-urlaub recht wobei bushido
hat er jetzt auch frau und kind
vorbild für die ganze branche konzils
vorstellen oder meinst es passt
eigentlich gar nichts im rappen ja aber
das hat ja nicht so gut tun wenn mein
kind haben möchtest du musst ja nicht
das problem
aber familie
das für mich im moment ist noch nicht
die situation da dass ich sage ich will
jetzt eine familie gründen oder ich kann
jetzt gerade viel zu viel unterwegs
schwamm offizielle sachen ich bin da
auch im kopf noch viel zu jung für dass
ich das machen könnte aber irgendwann
warum nicht
die schule auf jeden fall ein paar jungs
haben um mich herum natürlich auch gern
ein mädchen das ist natürlich auch aber
ein junger muss auf jeden fall da sein
wer das alles gut weiter vertreten
meinen namen weitergibt okay
was ist dann so dein wunschtraum also
wenn du keine angst vor der zukunft hast
also familie wann wird man kann es jetzt
vorstellen
dann kann ich mir das vorstellen
ich glaub ich muss dann aufhören zu wird
man einfach ich glaube dass also bei mir
ist halt so ein bisschen anders was das
betrifft ein bisschen hängen geblieben
ich glaub das wird auch meine familie
nicht so cool finden hast du das im
moment nicht auf dem plan also denkste
er von ich glaube man woche für woche
monat für monat oder
ich bin
zufrieden wie es jetzt gerade ist wie
gesagt die alten werte vorstellungen
habe ich abgelegt das sind wie schon
beschrieben also 15 16 17 jahre da hab
ich mir gedacht gut in zehn jahren noch
so 23 kinder als täter 2000 euro im
monat wies arbeiten einmal im jahr im
sommer was ich in den urlaub in antalya
und anschlüsse auch mal champagner stadt
moosburg
so das war's halt früher erfinder und
jetzt in deinen vorstellungen jetzt
meine vorstellung fashion week in
mailand
london
las vegas
weiß ich nicht südafrika mal ein
bisschen landschaft genießen es auf
jeden fall meinen horizont ein bisschen
erweitert okay
gut dann wünsche ich dir dass du den
diesen erweiterten horizont auch noch
eine ganze weile leben ganz häufig auch
danke ich danke dir das war der tag mit
summer jam und wenn er noch mehr sehen
wollt zum beispiel einfahren der erklärt
warum aber sagen album der letzte tag
deines lebens eine unterlassungsklage
bekommen habt dann klickt er das video
mit farid bang an nicht schlecht auch
der talk mit hans sarpei da berichtet er
nämlich davon warum er eigentlich gar
nichts von dem kult um ihn gemerkt hat
und wie lange es gedauert hat bis er
dann endlich draufgekommen ist also eins
von diesen videos unbedingt ansehen ich
kann versprechen dass ist sehr lustig
spannend interessant ach und noch viel
mehr klickt auf jeden fall eins von
beiden namen ist dann bei